I think they should take Bernanke's
approach which he says he's going to
keep doing until he sees more
improvement in the economy and I think
he's been mildly disappointed in not
hugely disappointed but mildly
disappointed in the rate of improvement
in the economy in the last few years and
therefore just the other day said he's
going to extend it further until he sees
it so he's not prejudging exactly when
it's going to happen he's telling you
the conditions under which he'll change
and the economy is getting better we are
in in an experiment which hasn't really
been tried before I mean we you know we
have it fed as a three and a half
trillion dollar balance sheet and and
buying securities is usually easier than
selling security system sometimes people
find out so we don't know how this game
plays out line and just the announcement
whenever was a few months ago or they
hint that the tapering was going to
occur you know that had some significant
market crashes probably a hundred basis
points or so on the ten-year and what
will happen when it when they actually
if they actually try to deleverage the
Fed I mean what has happened is the
American public D leverage and the and
the government leveraged up through the
Fed when the Fed if the Fed D leverage
is that in any big way that will be that
will be a new experiment and we were
talking earlier the question is when
they do that the economy has to be
growing fast and the basically doing the
piece people don't take into account as
they they're clear that they're going to
stay there until the economy grows it
has no pressure on it in fact you know
the Fed is the greatest hedge fund in
history I mean in you've got a trillion
won financed by currency in circulation
which doesn't cost anything they got
about a trillion eight or nine for the
banks of 25 basis point and I mean the
Fed is going to make 80 billion or
something like that the Fed is the
fourth largest contributor to the United
States government's revenues that there
is now that wasn't the case a few years
back but it's 80 or 90 billion a
probably and so and it is under no
pressure there none whatsoever to have
to deleverage so he can pick its time
and and if you have somebody wise there
and I think Bernanke's wise and I and I
certainly expect a successor to be it
can be handled but it is it is something
that's never quite been done on the
scale it'll be interesting to watch